superar los tiroteos en las escuelas
como el ocurrido el martes cuando un
joven de 18 años compró con facilidad
dos rifles de asalto y mató a 19 niños y
2 profesores en una escuela de globally
en texas el ex presidente de donald
trump ofreció una solución durante la
convención anual de la asociación
nacional del rifle la más influyente
organización pro armas en el país
seguramente todos estamos de acuerdo en
que nuestras escuelas no deberían ser el
objetivo más blando nuestras escuelas
deberían ser el objetivo más duro de
nuestro país
por eso que como parte de un plan
integral de seguridad escolar es hora de
permitir finalmente a nuestros maestros
altamente capacitados que puedan portar
armas ocultas de manera segura y
discreta
en la única escuela de este pueblo de
texas donde viven unas 200 personas ya
iniciaron con esta práctica
es una mentalidad diferente cuando
entras en ese campo si sabes que hay
gente aquí que está armada y que haremos
lo que sea necesario para proteger a
nuestros hijos así que creo que es un
gran elemento disuasorio en fitur
con la estación de policía a unos 25
minutos del pueblo los padres de familia
justifican la medida cuando salió por
primera vez no me sentí cómoda con ello
ya sabes no me gustaba pero en los
últimos años desde que se están
produciendo los tiroteos me siento
totalmente cómoda y totalmente bien
garbarek el estado de texas donde la
afinidad por las armas de fuego está muy
arraigada comenzó a permitir que los
profesores y el personal de las escuelas
lleven armas desde 2013 decenas de
escuelas han adoptado esta política
mientras tanto en washington continúan
los debates los demócratas quieren poner
en cintura la venta de armas mientras
los republicanos quieren reforzar la
seguridad en las escuelas con guardias
armados apostados a la entrada y la
salida de los colegios